Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Lale.
Hallo, ich bin Lale.
Ich bin Ersten. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Angelika Wothel.
Wothel, mit 2 T oder?
Mit 2 T, einem E und 2 L.
2 L, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Am 21. Februar 1970.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, ich bin so 86 Kilo.
Ich bin 1 Meter 68.
Was fühlt Sie es für uns?
Frau Doktor, ich habe seit 3-4 Tagen einen Husten.
Der wird immer schlimmer.
Wenn mein ganzes Körper tut mir weh, ich bin schwach.
Ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Meine ganzen Glieder, ich bin so stark Husten.
Ich bekomme nachts schlecht Luft.
Meine Nase ist trocken und es gab so ein starkes Karazin im Hals.
Ich muss immer etwas trinken.
Sehe ich aber auch etwas zum Trinken mitgebracht.
Egal, was ich gemacht habe, es hat nichts geholfen.
Seit 2-3 Tagen haben Sie einen Husten.
3-4 Tage ist immer schlimmer.
Bekommen Sie schlecht Luft?
Insbesondere wenn ich mich hinlege, das geht fast gar nicht mal.
Ich kann seit gestern nur noch im Sitz schlafen.
Ich kann ganz schlecht schlafen.
Ich werde ständig wach, weil ich Husten muss.
Ist das Husten trocken?
Ja, es ist ein starkes Karazin im Hals.
Es kommt kaum Schleim heraus.
Es ist eher trocken.
Haben Sie auch Herzchemalzen?
Ja.
Haben Sie viel?
Ich habe kein Fieber gemessen, aber ich fühle mich heute Morgen warm.
Das könnte sein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie etwas angenommen als Medikamente?
Ich nehme seit 4 Tagen schon Ibuprofen, 600 mg.
Das auch schon 3-mal am Tag.
Gestern habe ich noch zusätzliche Novalgien genommen.
Ich habe ein bisschen besser geworden, aber das geht mir immer noch ganz schlecht.
Haben Sie früher auch schon mal so ein Hebischwölter gehabt?
Nein, nein.
Waren Sie bei Mats?
Mein Hausarzt ist im Urlaub.
Und die Vertretung, die war weit weg, da konnte ich nicht hin.
Dazu bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ich hoffe, Sie können mir helfen, Frau Doktor.
Ja, ich hoffe auch.
Das ist ganz schlimm vor Ort.
Ist es schlimm, auch Husten oder Halsschmerzen?
Also der Husten mit dem Husten werden die Halsschmerzen auch ganz schlimm.
Aber es ist beides schlimm.
Haben Sie noch andere Schmerzen?
Also wie gesagt Kopfschmerzen, meine ganzen Gelenke, Rücken, Tunwee
und ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen habe ich noch.
Wo genau Bauchschmerzen?
Einfach der ganze Bauch, der Rumort ein wenig.
Ich habe kaum Appetit.
Ich trinke eigentlich nur noch Wasser und Tee.
Haben Sie auch diese Wischwerte für die Alte?
Nein, das haben Sie mich früher schon gefragt.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Aber das ging wie Erkältung oder das ist schlimmer?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist natürlich schon wie eine Erkältung, aber es ist schlimmer.
Ich hatte bisher immer Erkältungen.
Das ging in ein, zwei Tagen weg.
Aber so schlimm hatte ich es noch nie vor Doktor.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich.
Deswegen bin ich auch hergekommen.
Ich hoffe, Sie können mir helfen, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Dagegen nehme ich Medikamente.
Aber ansonsten ist nichts bekannt.
Haben Sie alle Entfüllungen?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Mein Hausarzt kontrolliert das immer wieder.
Ich meine, ich habe alle Entfungen.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck?
Das nennt sich Moment.
Ich muss kurz überlegen.
Amlodipine glaube ich.
Welche Dosis nehmen Sie da sein?
Ach, Doktor, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber das waren irgendwie fünf Getrauf, meine ich.
Einmal bis zwei Mal.
Ja, einmal am Morgen.
Haben Sie schon mal operiert?
Ob ich operiert worden bin?
Ja, ich hatte mir vor ca. 15 Jahren meinen Knöchel gebrochen beim Tennisspielen.
Dann hatte ich eine Operation.
Welche Knöchel?
Rechts, der rechte Knöchel.
Am Fuß.
Sonst haben Sie noch Operationen?
Nein, ich habe keine Operationen.
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Zwei davon habe ich mit Kaiserschnitt geboren worden.
Aber ansonsten habe ich keine Operationen.
Sie haben drei Kinder, das zwei Kaiserschnitts.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe keine Operationen.
Sie können Alkohol?
Ach, sehr, sehr selten.
Wie häufig zum Beispiel?
Nur wenn es fest ist oder wenn man etwas besonders essen geht.
Aber ansonsten nicht.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen?
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Als Student hat man immer wieder etwas probiert.
Aber das war zur Studentenzeit.
Was ich vergessen habe, ist, meine Nase ist auch sehr trocken.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich rieche auch ganz schlecht.
Beziehungsweise gar nichts mehr.
Das ist auch seit zwei, drei Tagen, oder?
Genau, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich habe keinen Appetit.
Ich möchte eigentlich nichts essen.
Wenn ich versuche, trotzdem etwas zu essen,
verschmeckt nach gar nichts.
Haben Sie in dieser Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, ja.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, jetzt sind drei, vier Tage.
Aber ich sage es wenig.
Ich bin sehr geschwächt.
Ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nachts, Schweiß?
Schützen Sie Nachts?
Nein.
Jetzt in den letzten Tagen, meinen Sie?
Oder im Album?
Nein, ich schwitze nicht, aber ich kann halt schlecht schlafen,
weil ich ständig husten muss.
Ich kann nicht liegen, ich bekomme ganz schlecht Luft im Liegen.
Das ist ruhig.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Strudelgang?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Sind Sie bereit, dass...
Ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Projektmanagerin.
Nicht?
Ja, verdockt haben.
Was meinen Sie?
Sie haben mir jetzt so viele Fragen gestellt.
Ja.
Manche sind Routinefragen.
Ich muss...
einmal alles fragen.
Dann machen die weiter.
Ich habe so starke Koschmerzen.
Können Sie mir nicht mal ein bisschen mehr?
Nein, ich habe so viele Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe so viele Koschmerzen.
Können Sie mir nicht mal ein Medikament geben?
Das ist ja furchtbar.
Wie lange dauert das Gespräch jetzt noch?
Das dauert nicht so lange,
aber wenn Sie sehr starke Schmerzen haben,
ja, natürlich können wir etwas geben.
Das wäre sehr gut.
Vielleicht eine kleine Infusion, Frau Doktor.
Ja.
Ich schaue mal, habe ich etwas vergessen.
Ja, muss ich auch Familien lang mitziehen.
Was suchen Sie denn, Frau Doktor?
Sind Ihre Eltern liebend?
Nein, leider.
Meine Eltern sind verstorben.
Woran haben Sie...
Sind Sie falsch verstorben?
Meine Mutter hatte ein Herzinfarkt
vor drei Jahren.
Und ich leider danach verstorben.
In welche Art hat sie...
Sie war 75.
Und Sie war 75.
Und mein Vater ist vor fünf Jahren verstorben.
Der hatte Krebs.
Und, ja, das war der Grund.
Vielleicht.
Wissen Sie, welche Krebs hatte er?
Hat er?
Ich glaube, das war Prostata Krebs.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Sohaze, sind alle jetzt gesund
oder hat andere auch ein Liebischwerde?
Nein.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Was haben Sie auch ein Liebischwerde?
Also, ich wohne ja nur mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Ich habe jetzt ein...
Ich schlafe seit gestern
in einem anderen Zimmer.
Und weil ich Angst habe,
dass ich meine Mann anstecke,
aber der ist bisher noch gesund glücklicherweise.
Ja.
Gut.
Was waren meine Fragen?
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte, dass Sie mir helfen, Frau Doktor.
Ja.
Jetzt schauen wir Ihre
Etaparanete.
Wir messen Fieber.
Ja, bitte.
Ja.
Wir geben auch eine
Anergetikung gegen Schmerzen,
Kopfschmerzen.
Ah ja.
Aber da muss ich sagen,
es fällt mir ein,
wenn Sie mir Schmerzen geben.
Ich würde sagen,
Sie haben das gegen Aspirin
und gegen Penicillin.
Sie haben das,
wird gesagt,
Sie haben Aspirin und...
Penicillin.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ja.
Okay.
Wollen Sie mir jetzt eine Infusion geben, Frau Doktor?
Es möchte ich Sie untersuchen.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie das nicht.
Ich bin jetzt nicht sicher.
Ja, genau.
Sie sind die Ärztin,
aber ich denke,
ich habe in den letzten Tagen so wenig getrunken.
Das ist eine Infusion,
ganz gut denke ich.
Aber Sie sind natürlich die Ärztin.
Schauen wir mal.
Wenn Sie das brauchen,
natürlich können wir das machen.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Also,
Frau Wotla.
Wotla,
sind Sie
gegen Corona
vollständig geimpft, also dreimal?
Ja, also meine letzte Impfung
war vor
1,5 Jahren.
Okay, die andere Frage ist,
hatten Sie Kontakt mit jemanden,
die Herr Keltschuk 7.0 haben
oder?
Nein, das kann ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern.
Nein.
Kollegen,
Müslmia
Schmerzlokalisation
und
Stärke
Fragen,
Kopfschmerzen
der Patentat
gehabt
und dessen,
die Schmerzen genau beschreiben,
wie die
sind,
wo die sind, genau.
Ja, wo sind die Schmerzen
und meistens hier an den Seiten
und dann hier vorne auf der Stirn.
Schmerzen genau beschreiben,
zum Beispiel
pulsieren
die
Domfdürkant.
Ja, es ist meistens
sehr dunkel, aber es kommen auch
Phasen, wo es mal
richtig pulsiert, wo ich das Gefühl habe,
das klopft.
Ja.
Kollegen, keine Fragen,
Sie haben gesagt,
keine
Schrafen
wegen
Usten
und Atemnot, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja.
Wie viel Kisten, wenn Sie schlafen?
Also ich sitze im Sofa
und schlafe im Sofa.
Hm.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Ihre Beine
geschwollt sind?
Nein, meine Beine
sind nicht geschwollt.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
Ihre Lymphnoten
geschwollt
oder?
Ah, Lymphknoten, nein.
Ich habe keine Schwellungen
oder Lymphknoten am Heiz, nein.
Das soll meine Frage.
Herr Dr. Leine,
was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Okay,
ich muss erst vorstellen.
Okay, gehen wir gleich
rüber
in Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Mhm.
Dr. Leine, ich muss so viel trinken,
ich habe Halsschmerzen.
Hm.
Herr Dr. Leine.
Herr Dr. Leine,
ich möchte Sie mit dem Gerät
mit dem Gerät.
Ja.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne
eine Patientin vorstellen,
die gerade
gesehen habe.
Guten Abend Frau Dr. Leine, Sie schon wieder.
Ja, haben Sie es?
Natürlich, bitte schön.
Was kann ich für Sie drunter erzählen?
Okay,
Frau Angelica
Bote,
aber ich glaube,
ich habe alte Fasche geschrieben.
Sie ist
43,
oder?
59,
54,
aber
die Patientin hat gesagt
Sie ist
1,61 m
groß
und
86 kg
Sie
stört sich
seit 3-4 Tagen
bestehende trockene
Husten,
Abschlagenkeit
und
Duspner
Sie
hat
keine
Sie hat
erst hat sie keine Fieber,
aber heute Morgen
sie fühlt sich fieblich,
aber sie hat nicht gemessen.
Seit 3 Tagen
nimmt sie über Profen
600 mg
3 Mal am Tag
und gestern
sie hat die
Husten
nicht
besser
gehen
deswegen möchte sie
sonst kommen
sie
muss
beim Schlafen
kann sie nicht
legen
sie muss
sitzen und so schlafen
bei den Allergien
Aspirin
und
Penicillin Allergien
bekannt
sie hat
außerdem
hat sie
Kopfschmerzen
Gelenkschmerzen
Bliederschmerzen
Abdominalschmerzen
ist
im ganzen
Bauch
Sie hat
Körperschmerzen
Sie raucht nicht
Sie trinkt selten Alkohol
Vorerkrankung
bei den Vorerkrankungen
hat sich nur
arterielle Hypertone
und
die Arterielle
Arterielle Hypertone
Sie nimmt
Amlöte 5 Milligramm
am Morgen
bei den Operationen
hat sie
Knöcher
aus der
Sentence oder
wie sagt man, ich weiß nicht
Sie hat eine Fraktur
am Knöcher gehabt
und das
operiert worden
Sie hat 2
Sexio
Ja
Okay
Sie hat die Kaiser
2 mal einen Kaiserschnitt
Kaiserschnitt
Genau
Ihr Appetit
ist sehr schlecht
und Sie
kann nicht gut riechen
Riechen
Also Sie hat
eine Geruchsstörung
Geruchsstörung, ja
oder eine Riechstörung, genau
Okay
Sturrank
und Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung
Wie ist
Ihr Geschmack? Hat sie auch
eine Geschmacksstörung?
Ja, sie hat auch
Geschmackstörung
Okay
Sie ist
verheiratet, habe 3 Kinder
und sie
ist Projektmanagerin als Beruf
Seine Eltern leben
ihre
ihre, ja
ich mache ihr als Beruf
Ihre Eltern leben noch
nicht
Seine
ihre Mutter
Nein, ihre Mutter
vor 3 Jahren
gestorben
und
er Vater
seit
vor 5 Jahren gestorben
Er hat keine Schwester
Sie hat keine Geschwester
Sie ist
vorgeimpft
Ich glaube das war alles
Okay
Was ist Ihre für Dachzdiagnose
Frau Kollegin, was denken Sie
Was die Patientin hat?
Wegen
Ihre Beschwerden
ist meine Verdachtdiagnose
ist Grippe
Was war eine Grippe?
Wie sagt man das?
Grippal Infekt
Tage
Ein Grippal Infekt
Okay
Woran denken Sie?
Sie denken an einen viralen Infekt
Ja
An welchen Virus denken Sie
als erstes
wenn Sie diese Symptome
bei dieser Patientin so hören
Das kann
Influencer sein
Corona
Wir haben jetzt aber Sommer
Herbst
Influencer zu dieser Zeit
eher unwahrscheinlich
Nicht
Was im Moment wieder
sehr stark im Kommen ist
und was wir
die Jahre zuvor hatten
Adenovirus vielleicht
Was war überall auf der ganzen Welt
Und haben Sie was von
Covid-Infektionen?
Ja, ich habe Corona auch gedacht
Aber ja
Covid-Corona-Infektionen
Okay
Das ist im Moment wieder sehr
ausgeprägt
haben sehr viele Menschen im Moment
oder mit auch sehr viel
sowohl ins Krankenhaus
als auch in die Praxen
Also das sind ganz
klassische Symptome
für eine
Corona-Infektion
Haben Sie
einen Covid-Test gemacht
vor Doktor oder die Patientin?
Nein, ich habe noch nicht gemacht
aber
Dann sollten Sie unbedingt einen machen
bitte
Das ist das erste mit dieser Symptome
Okay
Was ist Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Ähm
Als Differenzialdiagnose
betracht
Bakterielle-Infekt
vielleicht Pynomene
Okay Pynomene, gut
Sie machen
noch eine Naboo-Untersuchung
Sie wollen die Patientin auch hören können
Sie sagten
Sie hat schwere Luftnot
Was ist denn Ihre Sauerstoffsetigung gewesen?
Ich habe noch nicht gemessen
aber ich habe das
Frau Doktor, das wäre das erste
wenn jemand mit Dispne kommt
erst mal die Sauerstoffsetigung
gemessen
Sie hat eine Sauerstoffsetigung von 90%
Was machen Sie?
Sie braucht keine Sauerstoff
Oh, Patient
Frau Doktor
Alles was unter 93%
ist sauerstoffpflichtig
und muss ins Krankenhaus
Ich wusste das nicht
Okay
Sauerstoff
Wie viele Liter geben Sie
Sauerstoff?
10 Liter, 15 Liter
oder 5 Liter
pro Minute
Momentes 2, oder?
Sie sind die Ärztin
Was würden Sie geben?
Kann einer der Kollegen
ein bisschen helfen
Frau Doktor
Wie ist der Internist, Notärzt, Kandälogen
Pulmologen
Wo sind Sie?
Ich denke
genug
Wie viel? 5 Liter pro Minute?
50 Min
Das ist genug
Genau
Also in den ersten Minuten
hoch dosiert
5-6 Liter
und dann kann man runter auf 2-3 Liter
Genau
Sie messen die Sauerstoffsetigung
und das steigt ganz schnell an
auf 96%
Also Frau Doktor, wichtig
Sauerstoffsetigung unter Raumluft
sollte
bis 93% runtergehen
dann ist es noch normal
aber wenn es unter 93%
fällt oder 90%
dann braucht eine Patientin
Sauerstoff
und sollte
heute ins Krankenhaus kommen
Okay
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen haben wir noch?
Wir haben Pneumonie
Wir haben jetzt
als Verdachtdiagnose ein viral infekt
Covidinfektion
Woran denken wir noch?
Zinusitis
Der hat Hauptkopfschmerzen
deswegen dachte ich
An welche Viren
An welchen Viren denken Sie noch?
Welche Viren können auch solche Beschwerden machen?
Wo sind die Mikrobiologen?
Die internisten Pumologen
Intensivmediziner
EBV
Epstein-Barbirus
CMV
Zythomegalivirus
Woran denken wir noch?
Bei starken Kopfschmerzen
Differenzialdiagnose
Zupf für Brigretemperaturen
Schwerkrank
Schmerzen
Stärke, starke Kopfschmerzen
Ja, da kommt von der Frau Halle-Methierik ein Hinweis
Ja
Okay
Also, was machen Sie?
Welchen Testen machen Sie
für die Menengitis?
Ob sie eine Menengitis hat oder nicht?
Mit dem Kopf
Was haben Patienten,
die eine Menengitis haben
welche
klassische Symptomatik
Wie heißt das?
Eine Nackensteife
Die streckenden Kopf
oder beugende Kopf nach vorne
und schauen, ob der Kind
auf den Brust geht
oder nicht
Wenn die Patienten so da sind
und sagen, ich kann den Kopf nicht bewegen
oder sie halten den Patienten am Hinterkopf
dann kommt der ganze Oberkörper hoch
das ist so ein sehr verdächtig
das nennt man eine Nackensteife
Man osmie
Diese Tagbegriff
vielleicht
Okay, ich glaube das ist genug, oder?
Ja, ich denke genug
Sollen wir eine Pause machen
stoppen und vielleicht noch Fragen da sind
dann können wir noch diskutieren
Okay
Frau Dr. Lale, haben Sie noch Fragen?